welcome everybody to tonight's lecture
and the lecture is chess legends okay so
normally speaking and I would reach back
into the history and find some wonderful
games of Budd Vinick or Smith law and we
would learn the legends learn chess from
the legends unfortunately I can't do
that in the face of what has happened
today today was an extraordinary day for
America's highest rated player Hikaru
Nakamura he is playing in a super super
super elite tournament in Zurich where
all the top grandmasters of the world
were competing and he entered the last
day of competition one point behind
Vishy Anand one point behind today in
Zurich
they played five games of rapid chess
and Hikaru made up the deficit against
Anand and they tied for first because
they had tied for first Ananda Nakamura
had to play a Armageddon game Anand was
white in the Armageddon game and had
five minutes and he Carl had black and
he had four minutes but he Carl had draw
odds if he draws the game he wins the
tournament but Hikaru won the game and
as a result Hikaru Nakamura won one of
the strongest tournaments ever held and
he did that all today so normally I
would take a single game and go through
it carefully and we would understand why
this happened and why that happened but
as it's happening
we're actually going to see six games
five rapid chess games and one blitz
game and in the first rapid chess game
so we won't look at them the games too
in-depth Hikaru is white
Fabiana Caruana the world's number two
player is black and Hikaru opened up
with the English and it was a
symmetrical English and when I was young
this exact position used to be my
favorite position with white I did very
very very well with White's position and
I liked it very much so it is called the
symmetrical English and normally
speaking in the symmetrical English I
try to I would play this move a two a
three with the idea of expanding on the
queenside
many of my opponents played a six I
would play rook b1 rook b8 b4 takes
takes and I had this position numerous
times as white my opponents would play
the move b5 expecting me to trade pawns
and make an even-steven position I would
play c5 woo that's different and my idea
was would be to expand now to expand in
the center of a lot of my opponents
would play a 5 and I played Bishop e3
they were trade I would trade they would
trade I would trade so we get a position
like this and it's not any more
symmetrical is it it's not if not a
symmetrical position anymore and I had
lots of games like this that was not a
Cara's choice what he did instead is he
just played the move d2 d3 which was
rather a restrained choice
now we're back to a symmetrical and now
Hikaru plays a two a three which is a
kind it's kind of funny because when the
pawn was back here on d2 the pond
protected the night now White's not
really threatening the boovies rook here
an advance his pawn because his knight
is undefended so it's a kind of a
strange move to insert this move d2 d3
black plate C six Knight f3 97 rook b1 B
7 B 6
so in this opening it's very flexible
but the players can both choose from a
wide variety of plans and now with this
move B 7 B 6 black says okay I'll make a
double fianchetto I'll be in shadow both
of my dishes castles Bishop d7 Queen d2
can somebody explain Queen d2 to me
what's that young man precisely he he
protects the knight with his queen in
order to be able to advance his beep on
black stops him black stops white from
advancing his beep on the white does it
instead of two squares one square now
White's thinking I'll fianchetto my
Bishop to castles Bishop b2
and again the positions kinda
even-steven
d7 d5 so black breaks in the center
would be 75 and Hikaru plays the strange
move 91 so what Hikaru's idea is he
wants to open up this bishop he wants to
open up the bishop and at the same time
he'll excuse me he wants to support the
advance
B 3 B 4 by bringing his knight to the C
2 square so it's a pretty complex
maneuver but it has a very clear plan
black jumps into the center with Knight
d4 now here I was surprised by Hikaru's
choice he dropped back with his queen to
protect this pawn on b3 I'm not a big
fan of this move I think it's okay but I
thought it would be more sensible for
white to drop back with his bishop and
defend the pawn with his rook after all
the Queen's already developed and when
you moved your queen when he when he
karo moves his queen back he undeveloped
this Queen so I thought moving the
bishop was superior but this was C
Cara's choice rook b8 so this move rook
b8 simply tries to defend the bishop on
b7 so that there's pawns on c4 and d5
the pawn on d5 is an inner pin Knight a4
so what Hikaru's idea is he wants to
play the move III and to trade
dark-squared bishop black stops him with
the move e5 Knight c2 now this is a
tricky move the knight on c2 blocks the
defense of the pawn on b3 car you wanna
could capture the pawn on b3 he didn't
y-yes in men yeah so in this position in
fact Bishop c6 was carry Wallace choice
so in case of Knight takes b3 but why
could make a discovery against this
night excuse me this night on b3 by
taking the pawn on e5 and it's a trade
but at the end of the trade there's a
weakness on
square there's a weak pawn on d6 and car
you wanna didn't want to do that he
played Aoife Bishop c6 the knight came
to e3 Knight goes back to e6 so right
now both players are playing a
maneuvering game and things are about to
get wild
after this move whoa yeah wait a minute
is that a good move did Hikaru blunder
or piece he got fork look at that oh my
gosh how could Hikaru possibly save
himself yeah he played Knight to d5 now
car you wanna captured the knight but
White has a way of winning back his
piece how could he do it yes
yes that's what he did and it did it
with check okay then that's exactly what
happened so at the moment Hikaru has a
bishop for the night he has a
LightSquared bishop but that
LightSquared bishop as we're about to
see plays a crucial role in the middle
game that occurs as it turns out and
we'll see it in a moment the lights were
bishop on c8 see sex pardon me controls
the 8/8 square and that becomes
important as we'll see
94 Bishop d5 so the bishop pops out to
defend the pawn on e3 just a second
defending the pawn on e3 and he Carl
says okay but is that pawn on e3 good or
bad what do you think is it
it is kind of isolated but it but it's
there it's worrisome because it's close
in our camp yeah so it's a little bit of
both
it's a potential weakness but also a
potential strength and so this is a kind
of a tough one but it's a judgment call
that two very very fine grandmasters had
to make so Bishop g5 Bishop c3 so what
Hikaru is trying to do is advance on the
queenside and his opponent
fabbi is trying to advance on the
kingside and white advances and there's
a trade now notice that the a file just
got open with black why could put his
rook on the a file look though I cannot
put his rook on the a file that's
interesting yeah something going on back
there
h4 look at him go he's really putting
pressure on White's King site and white
says no no no I'm going to keep the King
side closed I'm going to play the move
g4 and and and stop the King site from
opening up Bishop f4 King h1 I found
this to be a very interesting move I'm
not sure I'll have to ask he karu
himself
I thought Hikaru had planned to play the
move h3 and put his King here on g2 he
didn't do that why do you think not he
did not do that
exactly maybe he maybe Hikaru didn't
like the idea of blacks bishop coming to
f2 and maybe the black queen would come
right behind so that was why in this
position hikaru kept this pawn on h2 and
just brought his King into the corner h3
b5 so the positions very very closed but
both sides have certain things that
they're playing for certain advantages
they're playing for rook g1 so the idea
behind this move rook g1 was to kind of
discourage black from ever thinking in
the future that he may play f5 as the
rook would be on the G file in
anticipation of that break King g7
Bishop a4 now here I don't know if car
you wanna thought that he needed to play
this exchange sacrifice rook e8 what he
was probably very afraid of was that
white was going to get a very good rook
rook a 100k SEK said yes well in fact he
could do it right now he could play rook
d7 on new variation rook a1 and play his
rook over to a7 but then I think he was
fearful that white would bring his rook
to a sex attacking this pawn on b6 and
in case the rooks were traded that this
this guy is really scary that this pawn
might get go too fast
so car you wanna made an interesting
decision I'm not sure it's a good one
but he decided to sacrifice the exchange
and he Karl captured and offered a trade
of rooks and now the rooks come off this
Bishop on f4 is an excellent Bishop it
really is but is it worth a rook mmm
that's a hard one Queen h4 very
frightening move ooh white black is
queen f2 is the very big threat that is
correct
Queen f2 and then bingo Bongo checkmate
so white has to be very very careful
queen h h4 rook f1 stopping the
checkmate threat Queen h8 I'm not sure I
know exactly what was on fab use mind
after that move Bishop c3 Queen a8 now
rook e1 so white is protecting the pawn
on e 2 so that his queen is not tied to
the protection of the pawn queen b7 look
back the g1 trades and Queen a warm ooh
now I'm not sure what was going on right
here after Queen b8 because look at that
threat what does the Queen and on b8
threaten yes absolutely so black has a
battery on the diagonal and he just
wants to snip off that H to pawn and who
knows what's going on what could lock
the Yak that could be devastating only
move g5 very good so that the rook on g1
has the square g4 Bishop takes rook g4
and now if it's White's turn white could
come over with his queen and capture
this pawn on h3 so black retreated white
played rook to h4 attacking the pawn h2
and now between whoa so now White's idea
is be careful beyond the alert Queen h3
and rook h7 is in the position for white
so black played Queen e8 in order to
yeah in order to get a check downstairs
King H King H 1 G 2 Queen d7
Queen e1 hmm what was that what kind of
move was that I thought to myself oh I
see look what he's planning
Queen h4 so white was planning to go
Queen h4 down here to h6 with a check
and then set up for rook e8 so Queen h4
the Queen's were traded and now it's
rook versus Bishop and pawn the funny
thing is it's not a contest the game is
over white simply wants to play the move
f4 a king takes h2 winning upon and
eventually his rook will come all the
way around the board to a 6 to win the
game car you on a plate f6 takes takes
and now Nakamura he Carlos said I don't
even need to win your h2 pawn I'm just
going to go after your b6 pawn and win
the game
gobble-gobble and fabbi said you're
right
I resign okay let's see the next game in
the next game Hikaru is facing one of
his many rivals in the world of chess a
two-time former world champion Vladimir
Kramnik the man who to throne Garry
Kasparov and Vladimir is really an
exceptionally strong rapid chess player
as well as classical chess player he's
one of those players who Garry Kasparov
described as a person who knows where
the pieces belong
he moved pieces naturally to their best
places so Hikaru started with a win he
gets white against Vladimir Kramnik and
the play is very common to a Catalan
one difference is white does not have
his pawn on d4 this pawn on D this pawn
on d2 is normally on the d4 square but
White has delayed the advance of his
pawn and black takes advantage of that
by putting his pawn on c5 okay a4 so
very uten common normal motif in these
positions is white is trying to create a
weakness white is trying to provoke to
create a weakness on the b5 pawn or to
provoke black to advance his pawn to b4
and then white gets an outpost on c4 for
his pieces Bishop d7 Knight c3 Queen b6
Queen b3 b4 mission accomplished White
has forced black to capitulate and to
advance his pawn why didn't why didn't
black
defend his pawn with the move Bishop c6
wouldn't that have been a good move
precisely the problem is after all of
these trades the bishop is overworked
and no longer protects the pawn on b5
so Bishop c6 actually would just a
blundered upon so be for a5 kicking
Black's Queen back and Knight comes back
to be one and then I comes back so the
knight is seeking to recharge itself it
wants to go night to d2 to c4 and then
it'll be a very good night instead of
where it is right now which is a very
bad night Bishop attacks Queen Queen
drops back castles 92 now why does we
lost White has lost a lot of time with
all of these wonderful wonderful
maneuvers and Black has an edge in
development but his nine on d7 that's
not such a great Knight and black is
going to have to look for ways of
improving his pieces and there he said
haha right away so blacks ideas he wants
to go knight c6 and maybe to capture
this pawn now white hoping hoping that
black plays Knight c6
why is knight c6 a bad move well what
could possibly be wrong with this move
yes exactly
e to e4 oopsy-daisy traps the bishop in
the middle of the board
Vladimir Kramnik is too clever for that
he decided to bring his rook into the
game rook a8 a7ii for see how the bishop
moved back and the rook developed Luke
c7 Bishop e3 oops
the night came back to d7 why didn't the
why didn't fly to my play Knight to c6
what's wrong with that
you take the punt aren't you afraid
aren't you afraid that this this game
aren't you afraid that this rook and
queen are lined up against each other
no okay very good I just testing so 97
very good move defending the pawn queen
and now again it's like one of the
things I really notice about Hikaru is
he's doing a very good job in
outmaneuvering a lot of his opponents
Vladimir Kramnik is a very very hard
player to outmaneuver but at the moment
over the last five 10 News White has
improved his pieces a lot and black not
so much rook c8 ePHI expanding in the
center 95 Bishop d2 so blacksmithing is
naive and worth a lot isn't he
h4 now in this position who would a
plane Age 4 I don't think I would have
I'm not sure what I would have done but
it wouldn't have been my first choice I
might have thought for example about a
move like Bishop to e4 the idea here is
just to improve the scope of the bishop
a little bit maybe I would play for
Queen h5 I might have considered f4 the
idea behind this move is that this
knight on d5 is defended by this pawn on
e6 so the idea of f4 f5 to undermine the
night so I might have thought about
those moves long before I thought about
h4 but h4 has of some very
nice things going for it in the first
place you kind of give your King a
little bit of lift and in the second
you're you're hoping that you will
weaken blacks king with H or an h-pipe
so see these moves knight c6 queen came
out to g4
the idea behind this move is pay
attention there might be a Bishop h6
plan in the position he paid attention
he moved this King Bishop out to g5 so
what black what White was thinking is
that maybe his dark squared bishop the
bishop on d2 really wasn't that good and
if if that on a good day maybe this
night could jump to the square d sex but
to be able to get away with that
maneuver the dark square bishops would
have to be traded so hikaru is looking
ahead on that one
rook c7 Bishop b4 h6
Bishop back to d2 sometimes it's very
hard to guess Hikaru's moves
I thought his intention was to trade
bishops I was wrong f5 you bet he did a
f5 fi that's a nasty fork of the Queen
and the bishop he did alpha saw Knight
takes ok also still a fork of Queen and
Bishop Queen takes pawn that was a
greedy grab I'm an admiration takes the
now can we take with the pawn
how come it's legal it's in the rules of
chess you could take with the pawn yes
that is correct
pawn takes would not be a good move
because the knight on c4 is unprotected
and your move rook f6 as a winner it
drives the Queen oops excuse me it
drives up yeah it drives the Queen away
from the c4 night-night and c4 loses
protection the knight is lost so that
was why he car we captured with his
queen Bishop f6 but now black has a very
good dark square bishop and some of the
squares around his King well they're a
little weak so he karo has to be careful
that he doesn't fall victim to a
counter-attack on the King side Bishop
e3 wrote their Queen here I wasn't a
hundred percent sure about this move
Queen to g4 I thought that Hikaru's plan
had been to drop back with his queen
it's a g2 keeping this diagonal keeping
his Queen on this diagonal and looking
to goups excuse me and looking to grab
this pawn on c5 with either the bishop
or even with the night but he Carl play
queen g4 and bang
Bishop takes b2 ooh that was a big
surprise whoa so he Carlo played rook b1
why didn't he Connor capture
don't answer all at once why didn't he
karo recapture yeah nyeeehhh
I you were thinking that one
and what about Queenie for Bishop c6 as
well as night at three check as a
Discoverer against the Queen
it was this move Knight e5 maybe if
white had put his Queen on g2 this would
not have been possible after Bishop b2
rook b1 the bishop came back to d4 and
black at this moment had won his pawn
back well indeed they this moment there
was a trade trade Queen e8 whoa now yeah
what's wrong he played in the game Queen
h3 but why didn't he play Bishop to d6
so the rook is being attacked so the
rook should move where to move the rock
rookie four and white and black gets out
with a tempo yes exactly like it's black
pardon me black gets out with the temple
with the tempo against the Queen
so Hikaru played the move Queen h3 with
the threat of Bishop d6 rookie two so
remember all of those moves that a Cara
made with a screen that kind of seemed
to go circling around you finally got
his Queen back on g2 after all of that
time yes Queen to g6 Queen f3 rookie
four so at this moment Hikaru stand
poorly and he would be very happy at
this moment to end up in it with a draw
but Vladimir is now playing for a win
Bishop d6 that's a tricky move blacks
Queen has to keep the rook on e4
protected rook e8 Bishop takes now do we
understand that move why didn't he okay
why check I'll take it
you just take the rook so it was just a
one move blunder the karo must have been
under time trouble because he could have
certainly played for example a move like
c5 supporting his bishop now black that
spans better that boy that was a big
blunder of the of the bishop and after
takes black is just a piece up and one
very quickly and resigns so okay so at
this moment Hikaru was not happy he just
lost and um he is like okay he is a
point behind anon and that loss really
hurt his chances of playing for first
prize in the term MIT now he plays
against Sergey karyakin
Sergei plays efore it's a French defense
the French tie rush these moves this is
a very very main line topical line in
the tarush all of these moves have been
seen before and this was a little bit of
a strange move for me h2 h3 I'm more
familiar with bringing the bishop out
right away and if the Queen moves to put
the bishop on this nice square e 5 I
think white has a has the advantage here
I prefer White's position h3 rub d8 and
rookie - I'm not sure that this idea of
rookie - is so good I would have put the
bishop on e5 I would have gone with the
old standard okay
Knight d5 so white offers black black
offers white an opportunity to capture a
pawn to take on d5 and to take well
there's a rook on e - defending the Ritu
don't be so sure so now again Hikaru is
offering his defy pawn as a kind of a
bait and he took the bait but look what
happened in the resulting position
bishops of opposite color even the
whites upon up he won't be able to break
blacks fortress the bishop blockades of
the pond and then black just brings his
king up the board and in fact carry it
off her to draw because neither player
that bishop on d5 just can't be budged
and then the extra pawn can't be
utilized
so at this moment with only two games to
go Hikaru has made 50% okay and now he
plays he faces his rival five-time world
champion this one Athan de nom and if he
has any chance sorry yes and if he cara
is going to have any chance of winning
the tournament this is a must-win game
and we get this position this opening b5
Wow yeah look at that
well black I admire vichy he just
grabbed the pond
okay the pawns may be doubled it a
little bit goofy looking but it's an
extra pond he grabbed it now a4 okay so
the idea here is white is trying to
create a weakness on b5 but also he's
trying his bush it is an ambush so he's
hoping to open up that diagonal one day
so Bishop d7
b3 and this was a very clever move I
thought this was a very good
move by this she said okay you can have
your pawn back go ahead and take the
pawn but as a result black now has a
protected passed pawn so long-term way
down the road if you get into some kind
of an ending this will be a big
advantage for black but Hikaru said okay
the positions very imbalanced now you
have a queen side majority I haven't a
majority in the center I need to win the
game I'll take a lot of strategic risks
here we go and the knight as actually
the knight on B 3 is simply excellent
it's a great block hater and it attacks
the pawn on c5 ok so a 5 Bishop e2 and
the players reached a position like this
and I think at this moment an on thought
his position was fine and it probably is
but after the movie for white is
expanding he white is using his majority
and the moment black cannot use his
majority takes c5 Knight goes back to e8
and Bishop takes so white pass pawn on
c5 that's an annoying pawn and really
annoying Knight e5 f4 knight c6 Bishop
e2 Knight f6 and I like this maneuver
that he car replace this move Knight
eetu why did he play Knight d2 yes so
that he could move either to c4 in d6 or
maybe even to e4 and d6 if you move to
c4 you just gotta
be careful that your knight doesn't get
pinned but putting that night on d6
would be so sweet right that's like a
fantastic outpost so black message it
messed right up black played Knight c3
he didn't take he took it now
and so black deliberately sacrificed
upon because he thought that he has
enough pressure and he was going to win
it back just a second let's see here
here here so this is a kind of a crazy
position right here
why didn't I couldn't figure this out
why didn't black why didn't Vichy just
take that pawn wouldn't that have been a
good move why not why not that's a snap
that pawn right off Knight to c4 I think
black has the chance to to capture so I
think black has the cat chance to
capture but white actually has a really
cool move you could go rook here
doubling the rooks it's not over Queen
here and there's a threat of discover
check
so what could white do
quit I actually saw Queen f3 but I think
it's the same my concept that you block
and suddenly black is pinned along the C
file that's a very nasty pin as well as
along the diagonal so that was why this
she didn't take the pawn instead of if
she played here here and he sacrificed
his Queen for this situation he gave up
his queen for rook and Bishop but he's
got a solid position and Nakamura is
going to have trouble breaking down
black's fortress Knight f3 and I don't
like this move that vichy played Knight
b7 in fact it's a kind of a funny
situation but if I could ask the the the
audience what would be the perfect
square for black's knight and then
exactly exactly I couldn't agree with
you more
that these squares d5 and f5 or the
perfect outpost for black's knight when
black played the move Knight d8 to b7
he's getting further away from his best
squares so I thought that he Carl would
have a hard time winning the position if
Vichy had played for example h7 h6 just
making lifts let's just make a move for
white for a moment H to h4 and now
knight c6 if the rooks are traded I
thought that it was vital that this
Knight get to this square or OOP scuse
me or
Oh cancel or to either f5 sorry or defy
and it's still a lot of hard work here
Black has good squares for his pieces so
I was a little bit surprised by this
movement OOP excuse me
Knight b7 and I thought that was a step
in the wrong direction
at the moment the knight looks good on
c5 but as we'll see it turned out not to
be so good on the d7 square Knight drop
back to f8 h v and now how is the knight
going to get to f5 it can it gaze it's
like it's like it's stuck and in the
meanwhile white may very very slowly
might take him some time but with
preparation he's just going to slowly
advance his pawns and he'll be playing
Queen against rook and the bishop and
white should be able to overcome fishie
finally f5 we get this position takes
rook d7 woo so rook b7 and whites
threatening Queen takes f7 and check and
mate
so rook takes Queen takes Knight Queen
here now you've got to defend the night
because the knight protects the rook and
so Bishop c5 was forced and now what did
white do e 6 Bravo that's exactly what
he did
opening up the e5 square for his Knight
woo now in this position besides Queen
f7 check and Queen take see 6 white is
also threatening Knight to d7 and all of
black's pieces collapse
yeah Knight d7 is a real nasty nasty
threat Queen c6 check I mean with one
move the yeah the Queen hits every one
of black's pieces the rook on f8 and the
bishop on d4 whoo
so this victory allowed Hikaru for the
first time to catch up to Vichy in the
in the tournament and there's one game
to go and he was black so he had to make
a draw this she had a chance to win they
both made a draw let's see how he karo
made a draw it's a Queens gambit
declined
Magnus no Magnus did not play in this
event he was replaced by vision on and
so this is the Alaska variation of the
Queens gambit declined and Levon Aronian
the white player is acknowledged to be
one of the world's foremost experts in
this position as white and so he Carl
was really going up against the best of
the best in choosing this defense and
Hikaru played it superbly it's
considered that White's a little bit
better than his pieces are a bit more
active and also that black Queen side
pieces have been developed so white is
considered to have an advantage but
let's see how he Carl handles the
defense so so far he's done a very good
job of just swapping off and trading off
some pieces this move Queen e7 prepares
the move rook d8
and his king is nice and lease safe
notice the King on g7 virtually
untouchable on the dark squares and
rookie seven Queen and interesting how
black started to move all of his pawns
to dark squares on the Queen side right
clearing the diagonal so Queenie hi
and after the trades now we're getting
closer and closer to a draw and I
thought this was kind of funny that
Levon Aronian brought his King all the
way over to the Queen side and when they
got to this position the players agreed
to a draw so that so so now the table is
set the two players are tied for first
and they go into Armageddon so in an
Armageddon game they usually do a
drawing of lots and the player who plays
the white pieces he gets five minutes on
his clock for all of his moves there's
no increment the player who plays black
gets four minutes so it's a minute
behind but the player with the black
pieces has draw odds a draw and black
wins the event so white in art if you
play white not Armageddon game you've
got to win there's that's the only way
you got to win okay
so the opening was once again a Queens
gambit declined and earlier in the
tournament in the classical portion of
the tournament that both players whoops
okay
yeah huh both players have played this
exact position as you can see so the
players had reached this exact position
earlier in the tournament and Hikaru had
lost to Vichy and that game had
continued just as the same way that this
game had so up to this moment they're
following their earlier game in the
tournament and this she played this move
Bishop e5 and that was not what he had
played last time around if I remember
right he had actually played b4 and the
game had gone like this and essentially
the difference is that Vichy had allowed
his bishop to get traded on the f4
square so I'm not sure why but and for
this game Vichy had this move prepared
Bishop e5 a slight slight difference
from the earlier game c7 c6g to g4 wow
that is really a sharp move how many of
you would have played that move really
you'd like that you like that you know
I'm not so sure that move is a real
challenge because essentially if the
attack misses you're making a lot a lot
of weaknesses on the kingside also when
you make the move G to G for you've got
to ask yourself a question where do I
want to put my king yeah it's always a
good question to ask especially in a
game of chess where do I want to put my
King probably white does not want to put
his king over on the Queen side because
black could easily open up the Queen
side do you want to leave your King in
the center normally it's not a good idea
but when you play the move g2g four it's
kind of like saying I'm not wanting to
put my king on the kingside either so
this was a very risky strategic move by
Anand Knight drop back rook came over
finally it was time to take that bishop
and now Knight to d7 offering to trade
nights we can see in this situation that
basically what white once do is he wants
to make a pawn storm you want to go h4 g
v h5 g6 and he wants to go after blacks
King one of the best ways of meeting a
pawn storm is to get out of the way
that's it that's the how do I face a
pawn storm get out of the way think of
an avalanche or an avalanche snow is
coming down the mountain do you want to
be down there where the snow is going to
hit you want to get out of the way same
with the pawn storm so with this move
Knight d7 econ plays it very well
he gets his knight out of the way so
that white won't be able to advance his
pawns with tempo Knight takes Bishop
takes whoa that's a very risky move f2 F
for essentially an on to say I don't
mind go ahead and give me a check I'll
move my king and then maybe an andhe
stinking that he'll try to lure the
bishop to h4 so that in the future after
the bishop gets to h4 maybe he could go
g5 and trap the bishop that's pretty
sophisticated the Carter said I trust
you I'm not going to give you a check
I'll I'll blast open the Queen side with
the move b6 and I'll keep that check and
reserve B for a5
and now this she opens up the queenside
pardon me hikaru opens up the queenside
we're trades Queen comes over okay so
what's the yes what's the idea of the
Queen coming over black wants to trade
on c5 and go queen bee - OH
raro then black is breaking through g5
takes takes queen bee for a white king
is getting into trouble now because of
this absolute pin against this knight on
c3 oh dear now you guys take over what
hold on let me get rid of the ha ha ha
ha
let me get rid of the ha ha well
whenever you pinned your opponent's
pieces or pin to piece the rule of thumb
is to put pressure on the pin piece so
this move rook a3 should come very
naturally to you or as Reuben fine would
say as natural as a baby smile rook a3
Queen d2 now what should black play